respirez vous n'entendez que le sandre
map doigts et vous vous abonner à cette
chaîne est tranquillement simplement
c'est quoi ce bruit dehors et vous l'a
été cette vidéo salue aujourd'hui on va
parler d'hypnose dans un cadre
scientifique et médicale et vous allez
voir à quel point c'est fascinant d'où
la fascination peut-être de l'hypnose et
on dit aussi les fascinateur je ne sais
pas qu'est ce que ça fait quand on est
plongé en état d'hypnose est-ce que et
comment l'hypnose peut-elle guérir des
phobies profondément ancrée est ce que
c'est possible de se faire opérer du
coeur sous hypnose est ce que d'ailleurs
c'est un mythe est-ce qu'il faut croire
ou pas en hypnose bien pour tout ça je
vous conseille de faire des recherches à
ce sujet très bientôt ciao wac
évidemment je vais tout vous dire mais
juste avant laissez-moi avoir
l'honnêteté de vous dire que cette vidéo
va être présenté avec le partenaire du
jour lui qu une assurance habitation qui
essaie de prendre vraiment ensemble de
ses abonnés qui ne cherchera pas à elle
à vous hypnotiser pour vous faire signer
n'importe quoi un vous savez le fameux
confiance
et
en ou l'autre version où il ya tellement
de trucs à lire et de petite clause dans
le contrat que satan d'or d'ailleurs
l'uqo c'est quoi c'est l'assurance
habitation 2.0 c'est une expérience 100%
digitale avec une souscription en ligne
en 2 minutes genre vraiment un service
client est disponible via un chat qui
est dispo 7 jours sur 7 avec toutes les
réponses à vos questions en moins de
deux minutes bref c'est tout l'inversé
des assurances traditionnel avec
lesquels il faut plutôt posé un jour de
congé si on veut avoir le temps de les
appeler et de solutionner les problèmes
lui causé une assurance innovantes en
plus d'être aujourd'hui la numéro 1 de
20 sur tech en france avec 180 milles
assuré lui qu utilisent la technique
pour réinventer l'assurance et la rendre
plus simple et plus rapide par exemple
il utilise l'imagerie satellite pour
l'assurance habitation cfoot sa dernière
chose ils ont une app qui vous permet de
suivre toutes les démarches en deux
secondes et on va pas se mentir ça fait
plaisir merci encore à l'uqo d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo si vous cherchez
une assurance habitation moderne
n'hésitez pas à visiter leur site le
gain est dans la description et vous
pouvez utiliser mon code de parrainage
fabien olicard tout attaché d'attaché
faut pas l'écrire pour bénéficier d'un
mois au fait maintenant fermez vos yeux
mettez vous allez sur votre canapé
détendez vous et suivez ma voix loïc g
comment sont simples c'est quoi
l'hypnose qu'est ce qui se passe dans
votre cerveau quand vous êtes sous un
état d'hypnose quand vous êtes hypnotisé
alors quand je parle d'hypnose je ne
parle pas des exploits de messmer et
celebi de teaser qui utilise cette
pratique à des fins humoristiques et de
spectacles dans cette vidéo je me
concentre sur l'hypnose thérapeutique
uniquement par l'hypnose de spectacle il
faut savoir que l'hypnose est un état
naturel durant lequel votre attention
est concentrée sur d'autres choses que
le monde extérieur votre perception vont
être modifiés et votre état conscient
laisse davantage de place à votre état
inconscient ce qui vous permet d'accéder
à d'autres ressources de votre corps qui
auparavant vous était inaccessible à
noter que ce n'est pas un état de
sommeil mais un état de conscience
modifiée on appelle ça un mc été
modifiés de conscience et je suis fier
que la grande question que vous êtes en
train de vous poser c'est est-ce que je
suis hypnotise abl moi je pense que non
je pense que oui en réalité la quasi
totalité de la population est sensible à
l'hypnose sauf éventuellement certaines
personnes qui auraient des maladies
mentales
lorsqu'une personne pratique l'hypnose
sur vous vous avez toujours votre libre
arbitre vous pouvez toujours décider à
tout moment de quitter cet état on est
loin du fantasme du mec qui te fait
tomber sensible aux sanctuaires veille
qui te faire tout et n'importe quoi
pendant très longtemps l'hypnose étaient
considérés comme de l'occultisme ou du
charlatanisme mais de nombreuses
démonstrations scientifiques ont prouvé
que l'hypnose n'a rien de spirituel ou
d'ésotérique en fait l'hypnose vous
permet d'interagir avec des parties de
votre cerveau que vous ne contrôlez
habituellement pas tel que le cortex
cingulaire antérieur zone qui jouent un
rôle dans la régulation du rythme
cardiaque la prise de décision et la
tension il est d'ailleurs bien connu que
l'hypnose a le pouvoir de guérir la
dépression les phobies stopper des
addictions ou booster sa confiance en
soi parce que c'est vraiment un pouvoir
je suis sûr que si vous pensez à une
phobie que vous avez vous vous dites
qu'elle est insurmontable hypnose ou pas
je vais vous raconter l'histoire assez
dingue de john thompson un jeune anglais
de 12 ans qui est restée bloquée plus
d'un an à abou dhabi par peur de prendre
l'avion en 2009 joe et sa famille
déménage et aux émirats arabes unis
après que tony son père et décrocher un
poste de direction dans un hôpital privé
quatre ans plus tard fin du contrat de
tony la famille décide de rentrer en
angleterre mais quatre mois avant leur
retour john développe une phobie aiguë
de l'avion la peur est apparu sans
prévenir
lorsqu'il a voulu faire un petit voyage
en avion avec son père la famille a dû
rester aux émirats pendant 18 mois et
c'est un traitement par hypnose de trois
mois par russell et minent ce qui lui a
permis de remonter dans un avion et ce
dernier explique que c'est un des cas
les plus graves qu'il ait jamais vu une
petite parenthèse la famille a dépensé
près de 40 livres à cause des vols
annulés des logements à payer et surtout
pour essayer de guérir leur fils de
cette famille alors ok pour les phobies
mais si on vous propose de vous faire
opérer sous hypnose qu'est ce que vous
en dites là y'a plus le problème de
croire ou pas en l'hypnose est ce que ça
marche l'hypnose est ce que ça existe ou
pas on vous propose vraiment une
opération sous hypnosédations c'est ce
qui s'est passé pour gérard un homme de
88 ans au chu de lille qui a été opéré
du coeur sous hypnose par une affaire
miyake spécialement formés à cette
pratique l'infirmière qui a pratiqué
cette hypno explique qu'elle est allée
voir gérard la veille de l'opération
pour discuter de son environnement et de
ses passions ce qui lui a permis de
l'amener dans un monde qu'il aimait lui
de se créer une bulle mental où il se
sent bien le jour j des l'opération
gérard était complètement transporté par
son voyage en thaïlande et sa passion
pour le jardinage et ça lui a totalement
fait oublier ce qui se passait autour de
lui le but étant de focaliser
l'attention du patient autre part pour
le détourner de la douleur et du stress
de l'opération parce qu'en réalité la
douleur c'est un sens on appelle ça la
nociception si je pince je vais
ressentir une information enfin j'ai eu
l'information électrique qui circulent
le cerveau de l'interpréter c'est ça la
douleur mais si j'arrive à couper mon
attention de cette information là alors
j'ai plus mal dit comme ça on pourrait
croire que gérard a fait cette opération
sous hypnose uniquement à vif or il est
important de préciser qu'il a quand même
été anesthésiés localement alors oui
tout de suite ça casse un petit peu
votre enthousiasme j'en ai conscience
pourquoi parce qu'il commande de
nombreux médias quand relayer cette
fakes news selon laquelle cet
octogénaire avait subi une opération à
coeur ouvert sans aucun produit
anesthésiant ses fautes ça a été déformé
par la presse gérard a bien été opérée
du coeur pour un remplacement d'une
valve mais pas à coeur ouvert sans rien
par ailleurs ce type d'opération est
assez courant et se pratique
régulièrement sous anesthésie locale
avec une prémédication sédatifs cela ça
veut dire qu'on administre patients une
série de médicaments anti stress pour
qu'il ne soit pas trop agitée sur la
table d'opération alors là vous dites
oui olivier
pourquoi faire de l'hypnose si on doit
quand même administré un anésthésiant
c'est ce à quoi je vous répondrais je
m'appelle pas olivier durant cette
intervention l'équipe du chu de lille a
proposé aux patients de remplacer la
prémédication part de l'hypnose ce qui
permet d'alléger la prise de médicaments
de chimie c'est pas mal parce qu'aucun
anesthésiant local se révèle toujours
indispensable en tout cas dans cette
opération mathieu rade anesthésiste au
chu de fort de france a bien voulu nous
expliquer comment se déroule une séance
d'hypnose et vous allez voir c'est très
intéressant et ça va peut-être vous
donner envie si vous êtes amené à être
opérés avant l'opération j'apprends à
connaître mon patient pour savoir ce
qu'il aime comme musique dans quels
lieux il se sent à l'aise et avec quelle
personne il aimerait être c'est
essentiel afin de bien cerner ce qui est
susceptible de le détendre pendant
l'opération car évidemment si la
personne a la phobie de l'eau je ne veux
pas l'amener à s'imaginer au bord de la
mer pendant la phase de préparation
juste avant l'endormissement je vais
tamiser les lumières prendre un ton plus
calme et amener la personne à s'imaginer
dans ce lieu qu'elle aime en utilisant
ses cinq sens pour certains ce sera la
mer pour d'autres ça sera devant un
match de foot je mets une musique qu'il
aime bien et c'est toujours très
personnalisé car pour certains il
s'agira d'un solo de clarinette
et pour d'autres de booba
l'esprit va rejoindre le corps puis la
fréquence cardiaque va ralentir
l'hypnose marche très bien et je
n'utilise plus de sédatifs pour calmer
mes patients il suffit de les rattacher
à quelque chose qui les rassure et ils
se sentiront bien il explique aussi
qu'il est essentiel d'utiliser des mots
positifs alors dit comme ça ça paraît
évident mais par exemple on va pas vous
dire vous n'avez pas de douleur mais
plutôt vous vous sentez bien on évite
tout les négations ne pas etc et on
trouve les versions positif des phrases
en psychologie d'ailleurs on a tendance
à dire que le cerveau ne connaît pas la
négation il faut pas se dire
je veux plus être malheureux mais je
veux être heureux il faut transformer ça
en positif parce que les concepts comme
le cerveau et associatif comparatif les
concepts qu'on les imagine les imagine
vraiment avant de le mettre en version
négative donc il faut phrase positive
mais en gros si vous dites vous n'avez
plus de douleurs à la place de vos vous
sentez bien ils vont entendre que le mot
de douleur qui va être du coup très
anxiogène voici un exemple captivant
d'une jeune fille qui s'est fait opérer
sous hypnose pour une tumeur au cerveau
pour continuer la détente je vous invite
détend les muscles du feu c'est aussi
une expérience intéressante pour le
patient parce qu'il sort de son rôle
passif pour devenir acteur c'est encore
plus concret pour la chanteuse guinéenne
à la mc entée qui a été opéré d'une
tumeur de la gorge elle était anesthésié
sous hypnose et a pu chanter pendant
l'opération
ce qui est rassurant autant pour le
patient que pour le chirurgien ce
dernier peut s'assurer de ne pas
endommager les cordes vocales du patient
qui sait que tout ce qui fait écho kae
du coup et puis d'une manière plus
globale prendre moins de chimie dans le
corps c'est quand même intéressant même
pour les phase de réveil si on peut
éviter la sédation médicamenteuse c'est
forcément au meilleur pour notre corps
en bref l'hypnose est très cool pour
permettre au patient d'être plus détendu
de mieux récupérer après l'opération est
de limiter les impacts des médicaments
et surtout leurs effets secondaires et
même si parfois il ya besoin d'une
anesthésie générale d'hypnose a de
sacrés bénéfices et ça marche
incroyablement bien pour les enfants
parce que si vous venez vers un enfant
pour lui mettre directement le masque
d'anésthésie sur le visage il va être
terrifié b de panique et des gaules il
va pleurer ça va pas être agréable pour
lui ou pour vous mais si vous venez en
me disant imagine toi dans l'espace
comme un astronaute et que tu l'emmènes
un petit peu ça va aller tout seul petit
fun fact pour vous montrer à quel point
l'hypnose à des ressources insoupçonnées
est ce que vous saviez qu'il était
possible d'hypnotiser les animaux alors
vous avez peut-être déjà vu cette vidéo
de poules hypnotisé en quelques minutes
dans dans les enclos
voilà bon ben ça c'est pas de l'hypnose
c'est un traumatisme pour le pour la
poule et en fait c'est physiologique ce
qui se passe donc ne fait jamais ça
certains font autre chose c'est ce qu'a
fait un plongeur aux bahamas courageux
ou complètement fou pour certains il est
parvenu à mettre un requin en état de
thanatos c'est-à-dire un comportement
qui simule un état naturel de paralysie
une sorte de transe chez les animaux
qu'ils utilisent comme moyen de défense
alors comment il a fait ça il a en fait
effleurer les récepteurs du requin situé
sous son nez qu'à provoquer chez d'euros
qu'à une immobilisation de 15 minutes il
faut savoir que l'une et des requins
dispose d'organes sensorielle très
sensible on les appelle les ampoules de
lorenzi ses organes permettent de
détecter les champs électriques et les
changements de température c'est ce qui
permet d'ailleurs aucun de s'orienter
quand le plongeur entre en contact avec
ses organes l'état de transe est
immédiat la respiration est plus calme
et des nageoires dorsales se raidissent
à noter que sa cause aucun dommage là
pour le coup chez le requin par contre
en tête éviter de reproduire
l'expérience le site si vous voulez
essayer de tenter plutôt sur votre chat
c'est un peu plus light pour terminer
cette vidéo j'avais envie de vous
quelques astuces pour faire de l'auto
hypnose parce que oui l'autohypnose
c'est génial pour vous détendre pour
éviter les troubles du sommeil ou du
moins les amoindrir etc en 2006 une
étude portant sur l'auto hypnose a été
réalisée sur 84 enfants et ados
souffrant d'insomnie 90% d'entre eux ont
signalé une réduction de leur temps
d'endormissement dont un car dès la
première séance alors déjà pour enlever
toute idée reçue je vous rassure vous
n'allez pas rester bloqué si vous faites
de l'autohypnose vous allez soit vous
endormir ce soit sortir de cet état
quand vous le souhaitez alors
concrètement qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire allez on se fait une mini séance
respirer installez-vous dans un endroit
confortable sans lumière sans bruit vous
fermez les yeux vous prenez une dizaine
d'inspiration profonde expiration
profonde le but est de vous recentrer
sur les différentes parties de votre
corps le poids de vos mains la chaleur
de votre corps vous prenez conscience de
tous vous observez toutes les tensions
tout ce qui est en contact avec votre
peau vous vous laissez aller en
imaginant dans un lieu calme que vous
appréciez par exemple vos dernières
vacances à la montagne dans une prairie
a lieu qui vous est très agréable à
partir de ce moment là vous allez
surtout faire fonctionner vos sens ce
qui est de vous rappeler les odeurs les
sensations les goûts imaginez des
couleurs des couleurs chaudes pourquoi
pas un coucher de soleil très
réconfortant et pour ralentir vos
pensées et vos rumination utilisé
l'image de la roue d'un moulin qui
tourne et qui ralentit petit à petit
jusqu'à se figer et en vrai rien qu'en
vous lisant je trouve que déjà ça fait
du bien si ça vous fait du bien dit ça
me fait du bien dans les commentaires ce
serait un commentaire bizarre moi
j'espère que cette vidéo elle vous a plu
j'espère surtout qu'elles soient apaisés
du coup je parle lentement parce que si
ça vous a fait du bien j'ai pas envie de
vous faire revenir comme ça trop vite
dites moi dans les commentaires ce que
vous pensez de l'hypnose on pourrait se
parlent et la prochaine fois de
l'hypnose et de l'apprentissage aussi
cas c'est passionnant
si vous ne connaissez pas je m'appelle
toujours très bien au lit car pas
olivier je vous mets deux autres vidéo
qui devrait vous intéresser aussi sur le
cerveau et sur des troubles et puis je
vous donne rendez vous très bientôt j'ai
pas la première prochaines dates de 10
mais si on est lundi ce sera vendredi à
18 heures si on est vendredi sera lundi
à 18 heures c'est tout bête prenez soin
de vous à très bientôt de charles